hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to SCP containment now
III will continue with my intended
objective of finding the area where I
can turn off the remote door control so
I can get into that exit II sorcerer
computer and get him to let me through -
heavy containment area but I wanted to
show you something first that I even I
didn't know about it I only heard about
recently so you may know this area right
here this is what's called I forget the
SCP designation number of them why how
and why how and why how and why okay no
all right what wolf I don't like that
okay but you may know this area here
because this is the SCP where it's just
a looping hallway of forever
you guys know what I'm talking about
right and if you've read the SCP dossier
on this particular enigma it's it's
really weird god damn it - [ __ ] you man
and the reason I have the mask on right
now is just because I'm going to be
doing a lot of running a lot of running
so if you if you carry on through this
door over and over again the whole
fundamental process of this isn't that
it just loose no this this hallway acts
as a hallway of infinite choices of
infinite possibilities of infinite
conundrums and if you continue to walk
down this path things start to go wrong
things start to go very very wrong so in
the in the wiki if you read it as they
continually went through this looping
hallway they send people to go through
this over and over and over again and
not only did it change
anything that they were holding on their
person it changed the universe that they
went into and I am not sure but I think
it even changed the universe that they
came out of and there you have it
hi okay all right then and so you have
well I seem to be zooming in and out of
that well I'm not going to look at that
for much longer but what I am going to
do is I'm going to carry on into the
universe of infinite possibilities that
we have here and we're just going to
experience the full well what we got
going on here okay hi
okay I don't know if anything else
happens after this but it seems to be
bad so I'm gonna keep going because the
the tests that they ran [ __ ] it's
whispering real hard now whispering real
hard now oh boy okay oh god okay what
are you gonna do okay video yeah I don't
know I don't have anything supposed to
happen out of this but I know this is
gonna kill me if I keep going
Oh alrighty then
okay I'm just gonna keep bolting for it
this difference I'm sure it will notice
noticeable fly me never look to the
right yet because you see I like that I
got a bad feeling that things gonna get
up and come after me that dead body I
guess that thing you know the thing that
that is
Oh
okay i'ma keep good hey guys there's a
good idea oh my god so just to give you
guys an idea
apparently this this has been in the
game since version 1.0 I've just never
seen it I've never thought to keep going
through these doors I've never seen this
I only heard about it recently because
you guys were talking about in the
comments and then I got linked to the
the wiki and then I've read about it and
I've read about it what happened
endlessly and and the redacted stories
that occurred after school walk okay and
the redacted stories that were added on
to the but okay
oh oh no no no okay I see it
I see how you be expressly [ __ ] with
me oh I see so what was the deal cuz
that guy looks like he's been shot in
the head and I'm assuming that's bad oh
but I'm gonna keep going just in case I
[ __ ] god damn it is that is he still
following me through all these different
dimensions because what each of these
hallways represent is a different
possibility of the infinite universes
that supposedly exist of unlimited
number by what the [ __ ] [ __ ] hell
I don't know what you're all about to
take somebody's okay you know that ain't
normal
oh my go ahead and say that ain't normal
that is [ __ ] weird that is [ __ ]
weird are you doing there
you're right buckaroo is good with
spinning there endlessly over and over
again all right I'm gonna carry on
yeah but each of these hallways oh my
god it's the same here I thought it was
going to disappear but no that is just
the way things are now
so each of these represents like an
infinite series of possible events but
this is this isn't this isn't just an
infinite series of possible that's like
there's like some bad happening as it
goes down because the testing revealed
like the doctor that sent them into
these tests and moving over and over
again because after only a few tests the
the possibilities only change to the
level of someone's hair with a different
color or the data set that they had was
slightly different the random number
generator that they had changed every
time they moved you know it was small
details like that I don't know if
there's anything bigger here but look
I'm gonna keep going for it good all
right okay all right now I'll put on the
gas masks and I'm gonna I'm gonna gun
this last bit hey why why why why
okay keep going why okay nothing nothing
is happening and nothing is good what
does it say on my navigator when I'm
doing this
where's my navigator what what what
where's my navigator where's my
navigator where's my navigator guys I
thought I had a navigator here seems
like just oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no
I think I might be stuck here guys
what happens if I go back can I go back
please
hello nope still the same okay that's
good to know
walking hi okay let's see this through
to the end I suppose oh I feel like I'm
gonna go mad maybe that's why my
navigator was replaced with a strange no
whoa hi maybe maybe I can't believe
anymore hello hi oh no that's just the
way that is I guess this is just
existence now so this containment breach
isn't just happening here it's happening
across multiple unit first is and I lost
my navigator which I don't like very
much I don't like losing that I like you
I'd rather have it with me
okay alrighty then
oh okay all right
haha hi okay you know you stay you stay
you stay toasty my friend you stay
pissed I'm gonna try to find something
useful
Oh what the [ __ ] what what what
[ __ ] what what what what what what
what what isn't okay that I judge a guy
that doesn't make any sense
stop quick crawling around me that
doesn't make any goddamn sense I'm in a
completely different dimension now I'd
like to say that right out I'm in a
different dimension and I don't know
what I'm supposed to do about that
oh god that guy is becoming very active
so I'm in a completely different
universe that is 100% to proof I'm just
in two different universe I no longer
have a navigator I no longer have
anything of use I don't know why I came
here and I don't know what else could be
different except for maybe radical Leary
I think I got to die at the hands of it
at pee pee here so I can reload and then
hi whoa [ __ ] god damn it [ __ ] where'd
you go would you go buddy you go huh oh
hi there we go so is it gonna say
anything differently about my death
d nah that was just there dude that was
so messed up that was so cool though it
was so cool that was so messed up though
but this guy I think was God by radical
Larry that's a definite yes on this
guy's poor face
okay go oh god a memory access violation
great cruel cool buddy okay so now that
we got that out of the way we know what
we need to do we still need to find the
door access controls but the only
problem is I don't know where that would
be because we've only got a limited
amount of ground to cover
but I know for a fact that we haven't
explored everything I just know that so
that's where I came from this is the
machine this is a Tesla gate that is not
operational right now and I'm gonna
close doors behind me so I don't get
killed going here
this is this all right there good okay I
hear that goes here what was in here oh
no this is where where 173 likes to pop
up
yeah he already broke through that
window so I don't need to stay here so
we're good there
load that up 173 is nearby where is he
whoa okay oh okay okay okay okay that is
not okay
that's not okay I know I said that it
was okay but it's not that is a hundred
percent not okay what's in here what's
in here in here I don't know if that is
what is that uh-huh what am I looking at
what am I looking at what is it
hang on what is it I need to drop
something
oh this 101 6 is currently a hole in the
cinderblock wall measures approximately
fourteen point five centimeters is
variable depth which change on based on
the current user a portion of the center
box is currently visible through the
hole no light source has been able to
illuminate it when activated when a
sentient being reaches into the hole
with the girth of their arm allows at
which point their fingers touch the
solid surface similar to current
location of scp-1162-j discover an item
small enough to fit through the hole the
atoms have universally been recognized
as something the user has lost we're
searching for at some point in their
life however upon retrieval the item
will vanish from the person of the
subject in addition any object placed
into disappeared what whoa what so what
so if I reach into this hole it's not
going to kill me that's what I'm getting
into this I lost my credit card
apparently huh Oh ah but I've lost
things down like my stuff what is that
oh come on you dick oh you dick POW you
dick oh no my stuff like what is that
that's my gas mask that I had oh you
[ __ ]
huh I done bad I got a I got a nosh [ __ ]
you could get lost in here you can get
stuck in here okay you know what I'm
just gonna I'm gonna load my game cuz
that is no good all right be right back
guys
okay so I'm not going in there and I'm
not losing my [ __ ] to that [ __ ]
so we're gonna deal with whatever else
we got I imagine I imagine you could you
can spend a long time and do [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
stupid music shut up yet droning bastard
alright so somewhere here oh and some
three degrees Oh close the door okay so
what we have here what we have here is
the elevator that I need this is the
elevator that's going to take me
underground to where those monsters are
I don't have time to visit this in this
episode but I will get to this very soon
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know how I'm doing down
the comments below let me know what you
think of that universal distorting
hallways was there another layer that I
did not get to thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]